[Music]
so kawhi leonard may be leaving the
toronto raptors after only one year with
the team which inspires today's pft live
draft the greatest one year stops in nfl
history and chris sims and i have both
learned while trying to research this
one there is no quick and easy google
for this one no
there is not annoying all right
yeah and let me tell you something this
is a day where you want to guess right
on the coin toss and if kristen if
there's ever a day you want to show
mercy on an old bag of bones like me
you'll press heads if he says tails or
tails if he says heads chris go ahead i
i think she i don't think she like does
it that way i think she's already got it
ready to go so i don't think there's any
like reacting to the moment but i'm
gonna go heads one more time i think
she's gonna go ahead i didn't like that
delay there
yes
yes damn it
i am on fire
she was trying to give us
crap no she wasn't yeah no she wasn't
yeah all right go ahead go ahead who do
you got
hey did i hear all the big wigs from nbc
were down there in west virginia
yesterday just wanted to make sure that
i heard that were they trying to talk
you into moving up here close to me will
you stop
did you go skeet shooting too you didn't
like uh didn't change anybody did you or
anything was by accident almost okay
that's good almost always good shooting
your bosses and probably help you with
your next contract yeah exactly all
right i just wanted to bring that up all
right i'm going deion sanders 1994 okay
san francisco 49ers to start off my
draft yes did you want that one because
i hope you did but i'm going to go with
that i mean dion sanders uh the doubt i
mean the san francisco 49ers they can't
beat the dallas cowboys they need
another playmaker they need a little
pizzazz on their roster what do they do
dion sanders becomes a free agent from
the atlanta falcons he goes and signs
with the san francisco 49ers and really
you know changed that team around to
where yeah we knew they had steve young
and jerry rice and ricky running water
waters and this great offense of you
know fire power but didn't really have
that household defensive player on that
side of the ball or just a a charisma or
way about them that you thought oh this
is one of the better defenses in
football and dion brought that to the
san francisco 49ers i mean of course he
was the best corner in football the best
corner maybe in the history that we'd
ever seen at that point i mean it was
deion sanders on the island shut down
but hey some of the interceptions he had
the pick sixes he had all of that uh you
know just so impressive and of course
helped lead them to uh a super bowl
victory over the san diego chargers did
you already have that one or was that
fed to you by steve nope i already had
that one that one see i can do some of
the good ones off the top of my head
it's just some of the other ones
man i don't know i'm a little nervous
about the rest of my list well let me
tell you i'm glad you didn't try to go
two for the price of one because dion
sanders 2000 is pick number two that's
how good dion sanders was he went to
washington for one year and only one
year in large part because he wanted
nothing to do with marty schottenheimer
as the head coach in 2001. he was part
of that team that was supposed to win
the super bowl didn't even get to the
playoffs in 2000 but he's still dion
sanders yes if you get one year with
deion sanders it's a great year with
deion sanders right and that was
actually his last year in football he
retired in 2001 tried to unretire in
2002 to join the raiders the chargers
put in a claim on his rights coached at
the time by marty schottenheimer the guy
he tried to avoid in washington and then
came out of retirement 2004 and 2005
with the ravens but the one-year stop
with washington
not because of what the team did but
because he's dion sanders that's one of
the all-time great one-year stops in nfl
history that is that i mean it is a
course i mean yeah to watch dion sanders
any team that's there but oh good i'm
glad you picked that one because now i
just i won the draft especially when i
go with daryl darrell rivas 2014 new
england patriots
wham bam thank you ma'am right there i
mean hey darrell rivas we know the new
england patriots this is really the
start of this oh we're gonna play
man-to-man and put our corner up against
your best receiver or our best corner is
going to take out your number two
receiver and we're going to formulate a
defense to take away everything else and
uh darrell rivas of course was de rivas
island one of the best corners in
football he's certainly in the
conversation for one of the greatest
corners of all time at least in my book
but going from the jets and then having
that year to go to new england who
hadn't won the super bowl in a few years
and he goes there and adds a little
pizzazz on their defense and a guy that
they could trust to shut down some of
the top receivers in the game and they
go on to win super bowl 49 and beat the
seattle seahawks and uh he made a lot of
money and of course that was it you know
that was it for the year because the the
new york jets paid them a ton of money
to come back to new york after that but
that goes down as one of the greatest
one-year stops i can remember
stats gave me that one
you blew it and you blew it because you
know why stats you blew it is it two
years right team
no oh
gosh okay
right team
right year
right position
wrong guy because if i recall correctly
when that super bowl was won super bowl
49 in arizona darrell rivas had nothing
to do with the play that ultimately
secured the victory and even though it
was malcolm butler who made the
interception it was a guy named brandon
browner okay i played for the seahawks
the year before knew that play
knew that formation knew that moment and
and the the most underrated super bowl
hero of the last 25 years because he
grabbed his guy and kept him from
picking malcolm butler allowing malcolm
butler to get through and intercept the
pass brandon browner the better of the
two guys on that day you could argue the
better of the two guys that year and
also there was a report back in 2016
that brandon browner actually punched
derral rivas in the face at one point
during the season thereby establishing
his dominance making him the alpha
between the two brandon brown are the
better one-year stop between him and
darrell rivas checkmate that is a good
one i mean i like the pick it's
certainly not as good as mine but it's a
really good under the radar pick by you
there that i did not think of and
certainly one of the more underrate
under the radar yes selfless plays
that's not going to get attention for
for one single guy because malcolm
butler steals the thunder there but yeah
that was a big time moment for brandon
batter and brandon brenner and he was a
part of that you know uh legion of boom
the uprising of that seattle defense he
was pretty damn special there for a
little while okay
um to end good luck now you're done no
this is another one um you forgot about
this one this is a good one 1996 green
bay packers
desmond howard he was only there for one
year
that's the one that i had on my list
downstairs that i forgot about dammit
gosh darn it if you only didn't work at
your house you could go and get oh
that's right you do work at your house
you could have got your list what is it
like five feet away from you know
it's a long walk yeah can't hide money
that's when you know you've got a long
walk you've got a big house
but desmond howard you know led the nfl
and punt return yards that year and then
of course one super bowl mvp and that's
a pretty special one-year uh showing for
a franchise the green bay packers hadn't
won a championship in so long and
desmond howard was certainly a huge huge
help in that how about wait this
do you remember desmond howard in the
divisional playoff game was in the
locker room taking a pee and they kicked
the ball off and he wasn't back there to
return the kick in that same year and
the 49ers recovered the second half
opening kickoff i think that's one of
the great stories of that year that no
one was there nobody was there he didn't
tell anybody he was in the restroom look
it up
1996 playoffs they're playing the 49ers
the divisional playoff game started the
second half they kicked the ball off and
desmond howard wasn't back there deep
because he was still in the restroom and
the 49ers recovered the opening kickoff
of the second half because he wasn't
there that's unbelievable but that's how
good the packers were they could still
win a game like that
and and that's how good desmond howard
was he didn't get abruptly cut from the
team right right for not being on the
field that that takes what ty montgomery
did to a whole new level at least
montgomery was on the field when he
screwed up this year for the packers all
right look i could go a lot of different
directions here and uh yeah i wouldn't
have been able to get desmond howard
anyway because i still liked the brandon
browner pick although in hindsight i
guess i could have sandbagged you
because you weren't even thinking about
it yeah there are other guys that i
could go with i could go with brett
favre his one year with the jets but you
know what and they weren't that great
they were eight and three and then it
all fell apart because you had torn
biceps
i could go kurt warner 2004 with the
giants but he got benched halfway
through the season i could go robert
edwards because he was a rookie with the
patriots in 1998 had 1100 rushing yards
tore up his knee playing beach football
at a good run so it's really not the
same though i mean that that's not a
one-year stop right it wasn't a
one-year-old kawhi leonard-ish right
yeah so so here's what i'm going to do
because it truly was a one-year
arrangement and this is a forgotten part
of nfl history and since we are
celebrating the 100th season of the nfl
this year we have to turn the clock back
to 19 and 43 because for one year and
one year only due to the uh limited
players available because of world war
ii they took the pittsburgh steelers and
the philadelphia eagles and they melded
them into one team for one year earlier
they were unofficially known as the
steagles that's awesome now they didn't
do anything they didn't win the
championship but for one year and one
year only the two
cities on the opposite spectrums of the
of the uh of pennsylvania came together
and they made the steagles for one year
that's that's all i got that's that's
okay that's a cool one nonetheless i
mean once i heard you go in there the
1943 i thought about that it is amazing
they combined their names and full
transparency just because i annihilated
you in this draft so badly i got a lot
of help from stats today it was a
collaborative effort yeah yeah
collaborative whooping it was just
totally i could tell during the break i
could tell during the break that that's
what you were talking about it was not
easy to google these i usually can do
these drops off the top of my head i
usually don't even have to worry about
researching it and i looked it up last
night and i said damn i can't find
anything i said i'll figure it out in
the morning and i sat here to start the
show and i was like holy cow we're an
hour in and i only got one or two here
i'm in deep crap here so that's when i
had to call in the uh stats help
i i thought of deion sanders both of
them yeah i thought of desmond howard
but forgot i thought of brandon browner
uh and yeah i basically i you know this
was this was a difficult one because
there's no easy way there's no easy
search term to try to unlock a category
of uh specific niche player or or
franchise like we ultimately did so
chris had dion sanders in 94
darrell rivas in 2014 desmond howard in
96. i've got dion in 2000 brandon
browner in 2014 and the 1943
pittsburgh philadelphia
steagles
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports